From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass, and this is our 500th episode. And what does that feel like? Well, it feels like both a milestone and it feels like nothing. It fills like an odometer clicking over.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯，这是我们的第 500 期节目。感觉如何？嗯，它既像是一个里程碑，又感觉什么都不是。就像里程表又跳了一格一样。
I was talking to the show's senior producer, Julie Snyder, about this. She's been here for 15 of the show's 17 years, since episode number 58.
我曾与节目的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德谈过这件事。她在我们节目十七年的历史中待了十五年，从第 58 期开始就在这里了。
Five hun-- what-- I just-- I just come to work. I do my job. I go home.
五百……什么？我只是……我只是来上班。做好我的工作。然后回家。
Play each ballgame the best I can.
尽我所能打好每一场比赛。
Yeah, exactly.
没错，就是这样。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, it really is a blur.
不，这真的就像是一场模糊的记忆。
It is a blur. And over the last few weeks here at the radio show, we talked about what we should do for the 500th episode. And like, first of all, should we mark it at all? You know what I mean? Like 500 shows on the radio actually isn't that big of a deal for most programs. Like Terry Gross, she knocks through 500 shows like every two years. Doesn't even notice. Just spins right by them. Lots of shows are like that.
确实很模糊。过去几周，我们一直在讨论第 500 期节目该做些什么。首先，我们真的需要纪念它吗？你懂我的意思吗？在大多数电台节目中，500 期其实并不是什么大不了的事。像特里·格罗斯，她可能每两年就做满 500 期了。她甚至都不会注意到。就这样过去了。很多节目都是这样。
But, you know, the kind of show that we do here, it takes three or four months to make each episode. So that is different. And besides that, you know, 500, the number 500-- that is a number you notice. And if we didn't do something today, like that would feel weird, you know?
但是，你知道，我们做的这种节目，每一期都要花三四个月来制作。所以这不一样。而且除此之外，500 这个数字——这是一个你会注意到的数字。如果我们今天不做点什么，那感觉会很奇怪，你懂吗？
So anyway, so as we talked about different things that we could do for this episode, at some point, Julie had the idea that it might be fun to go back to the archives and choose favorite moments from the last 499 episodes. And all this hour, you're going to be hearing the producers of the program, the people who find the stories and who put them together each week, talking about their very favorite moments that we have ever put on the radio.
总之，当我们讨论这期节目能做些什么时，朱莉有个想法，或许回到档案库，选出过去 499 期里最喜欢的时刻会很有趣。在这一小时里，你将听到节目的制作人，也就是每周寻找故事并将它们编排在一起的人，讲述他们有史以来在电台播放过的最喜欢的时刻。
And the reasons that the producers picked their favorites, I think, are different than the reasons that most listeners would give. Some of them chose stories that had been, I have to say, completely forgotten by the rest of the staff for years. Some chose just, like, one little section of script. Some chose, like, a scene that secretly made them cry and they never told the rest of us. They said things like this.
我认为，制作人们选择这些片段的理由，与大多数听众给出的理由并不相同。有些人选择了那些我必须说，已经被其他同事遗忘了多年的故事。有些人只选了一小段台词。有些人选了一个让他们私下流泪但从未告诉过我们的场景。他们说了这样的话。
When I heard that, I was like, wow, that's one articulate bank robber.
当我听到那个的时候，我就想，哇，那真是一个能言善辩的银行劫匪。
And then as it unfolds, you just realize, like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
然后随着故事的展开，你意识到，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。
I felt like I'd been hit by a car or something. But in a nice way. [LAUGHS]
我感觉就像被车撞了一样，或者类似的感觉。但那种感觉还不错。[笑]
It just made me really mad. Do you remember this? (STAMMERING)  It's mind-blowing.
它真的让我很生气。你还记得这个吗？（结巴）这简直让人大开眼界。
And so I am really excited to play you the stuff that we have found. And let's just jump in.
所以我非常兴奋能为你播放我们找到的这些片段。让我们直接开始吧。
Julie Snyder, our senior producer, is the mastermind behind a lot of our most ambitious shows, like Harper High School episodes, if you've heard those. And she came into the studio with a list of favorite stories from over the years, starting with a shortie.
我们的高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德是我们许多宏大节目的幕后操盘手，比如如果你听过的话，《哈珀高中》那几期。她带着一份多年来最喜欢的节目列表走进录音室，从一个简短的开始。
It's only like a minute long.
它只有一分钟长。
OK.
好的。
It's really, really lovely writing that I have thought about ever since it aired, I don't know, 12 years ago, 14 years ago.
那是一段非常非常优美的文字，自从它在大约 12 年前、14 年前播出以来，我就一直记在心里。
Wow. What in the world are you talking about?
哇。你到底在说什么？
It's from Sarah Vowell's Trail of Tears story. Can you guess it?
来自莎拉·沃威尔的《泪之径》故事。你能猜到吗？
Hold on.
等等。
That's a whole show.
那可是整整一期节目。
Like America is a country that hits you but-- that's not the moment.
比如“美国是一个会重创你的国家”，但……那不是那一刻。
It is.
就是那一刻。
It is?
是吗？
It is.
是的。
I can't remember the set-up for it. I just remember the punchline of it.
我不记得它的铺垫了。我只记得它的点睛之笔。
Well, the set-up-- OK. Well, so the story, right, is that Sarah is part Cherokee. And she and her twin sister Amy go on this road trip, going from Georgia driving to Oklahoma, following the Trail of Tears. And--
好吧，铺垫是这样的……好吧，故事是说莎拉是切罗基人。她和她的双胞胎妹妹艾米进行了一次公路旅行，从佐治亚州开车到俄克拉荷马州，沿着“泪之径”。然后……
That their ancestors had walked before them.
那是她们的祖先曾走过的路。
Exactly. That their ancestors have walked when the Cherokee were expelled from Georgia. And it's super depressing. I mean, what would a trip like that be? It is. It's just depressing. So it's very hard to know what to do with all these feelings. And so that's where her writing picks up. You want to hear it?
没错。那是切罗基人被逐出佐治亚州时，她们的祖先走过的路。那非常令人沮丧。我是说，那样的旅行会是什么样？确实如此。非常令人沮丧。所以很难知道该如何处理这些感受。这就是她那段文字的切入点。你想听听吗？
Yeah.
想。
OK. It's "Trail of Tears," starting at 45:14.
好的。那是《泪之径》，从 45 分 14 秒开始。
OK, here we go.
好的，我们开始。
[MUSIC - CHUCK BERRY, "BACK IN THE USA"]
[音乐 - 查克·贝里，《回到美国》]
The most happiness I find on the trip is when we're in the car and I can blare the Chuck Berry tape I brought. We drive the trail where thousands died, and I listen to music and think, what are we supposed to do with the grizzly past? I feel a righteous anger and bitterness about every historical fact of what the American nation did to the Cherokee. But at the same time, I'm an entirely American creature. I'm in love with this song and the country that gave birth to it.
在这次旅行中，我最快乐的时候是我们在车里，我能大声播放我带来的查克·贝里的磁带。我们开在成千上万人死去的路上，我听着音乐想，我们该如何面对这段残酷的过去？我对美国民族对切罗基人所做的一切历史事实感到一种正义的愤怒和痛苦。但同时，我是一个彻头彻尾的美国生物。我爱这首歌，也爱这个孕育了它的国家。
[MUSIC - CHUCK BERRY, "BACK IN THE USA"]
[音乐 - 查克·贝里，《回到美国》]
Listening to "Back in the USA" while driving the Trail of Tears, I turn it over and over in my head. It's a good country. It's a bad country. Good country. Bad country. And of course, it's both. When I think about my relationship with America, I feel like a battered wife. Yeah, he knocks me around a lot, but boy, he sure can dance.
在沿着“泪之径”开车时听着《回到美国》，我在脑海里一遍遍地思索。这是一个好国家。这是一个坏国家。好国家。坏国家。当然，两者皆是。当我想起我与美国的关系时，我感觉自己像个受虐的妻子。是的，他经常打我，但天哪，他确实很会跳舞。
[MUSIC - CHUCK BERRY, "BACK IN THE USA"]
[音乐 - 查克·贝里，《回到美国》]
Isn't that so nice?
这不是很美好吗？
It's perfect.
太完美了。
I know. I remember-- I remember when she wrote it.  I remember reading it. I remember when it aired. I just thought it was great. I love that writing. And I think about it all the time. I think about it for so many times when trying to put stuff-- like how do you hold two thoughts together?
我知道。我记得……我记得她写这段话的时候。我记得读过它。我记得它播出的时候。我只是觉得它太棒了。我喜欢那种文字。我无时无刻不在想它。当试图把某些东西组合在一起时，我经常会想起它——比如你如何同时持有两种想法？
You mean about this country?
你是说关于这个国家的想法？
Yes. All right, you want another one?
是的。好了，还要再来一个吗？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
OK, you want to do "Testosterone"?
好的，你想听《睾酮》那一期吗？
Sure.
当然。
All right. I really do-- so this is another one. I'll just continue to do these through how they personally affected me.
好吧。我真的很……所以这是另一个。我会继续根据它们对我的个人影响来介绍这些。
Good.
好的。
So "Testosterone," this is the one where I feel so bad for you guys. I feel really bad for men. This blew my mind, the interview that Alex did with Griffin Hansbury.
那么，《睾酮》，这是我为你们感到非常抱歉的一期。我真的很为男性感到同情。这让我大开眼界，亚历克斯对格里芬·汉斯伯里的采访。
Griffin Hansbury.
格里芬·汉斯伯里。
Yeah. And so Griffin was talking to Alex about-- Griffin was born a woman and went to Bryn Mawr, and was a feminist, and really-- you know what I mean?
是的。格里芬在和亚历克斯谈论……格里芬生来是女性，去了布林茅尔学院，曾是女权主义者，而且真的……你懂我的意思吗？
Yeah, lesbian feminist.
是的，女同性恋女权主义者。
Lesbian feminist. And then so then, Griffin decided to transition, and so he started taking testosterone. And he started taking pretty intense amounts, apparently.
女同性恋女权主义者。然后，格里芬决定变性，所以他开始服用睾酮。显然，他开始服用的剂量相当大。
Like way more than a man has.
比如比普通男性多得多。
Yeah, it's like, I think, twice. And so this part of the interview is when Griffin is telling Alex about the effects of the testosterone.
是的，我想是两倍。采访的这一部分是格里芬向亚历克斯讲述服用睾酮后的效果。
The most overwhelming feeling is the incredible increase in libido and change in the way that I perceived women and the way I thought about sex. Before testosterone, I would be riding the subway, which is the traditional hotbed of lust in the city. And I would see a woman on the subway, and I would think, she's attractive. I'd like to meet her.
最强烈的感受是性欲的极大增加，以及我对女性感知的改变，还有我思考性的方式。服用睾酮之前，我会坐地铁，那是城市里传统的欲望温床。我会看到一个女性，我会想，她很有吸引力。我想认识她。
What's that book she's reading? I could talk to her. This is what I would say. There would be a narrative. There would be this stream of language. It would be very verbal.
她在读什么书？我可以和她谈谈。这就是我会说的话。会有一个叙事过程。会有语言流。那会是非常言语化的。
After testosterone, there was no narrative. There was no language, whatsoever. It was just, I would see a woman who was attractive-- or not attractive.  She might have an attractive quality, nice ankles or something, and the rest of her would be fairly unappealing to me. But that was enough to basically just flood my mind with aggressive pornographic images, just one after another.
服用睾酮后，没有了叙事。完全没有语言。只是，我会看到一个有吸引力的女性——或者没那么有吸引力。她可能有一个迷人的特质，比如漂亮的脚踝之类的，而她身体的其他部分对我来说相当没有吸引力。但这足以让我脑子里充斥着侵略性的色情图像，一个接一个。
It was like being in a pornographic movie house in my mind. And I couldn't turn it off. I mean, I could not turn it off. Everything I looked at, everything I touched turned to sex.
就像我的大脑里住进了一家色情电影院。我无法关掉它。我是说，我根本无法关掉它。我看着的一切，我触摸的一切都变成了性。
What did you do with that? I mean, what did you think?
你对此做了什么？我是说，你怎么想？
Well, I felt-- I felt like a monster, a lot of the time. And it made me understand men. It made me understand adolescent boys, a lot. Suddenly, hair sprouting, and I'm turning into this beast. And I would kind of-- I would really kind of berate myself for it.
嗯，我感觉……我感觉自己像个怪物，很多时候。这让我理解了男性。这让我非常理解青春期的男孩。突然间，毛发滋生，我变成了这种野兽。我会有点……我真的会因此而责骂自己。
I remember walking up Fifth Avenue, and there was a woman walking in front of me. And she was wearing this little skirt and this little top. And I was looking at her ass. And I kept saying to myself, don't look at it, don't look at it. And I kept looking at it.
我记得走在第五大道上，前面有个女人走着。她穿着小裙子和小上衣。我一直在盯着她的屁股。我一直对自己说，别看，别看。但我一直看着它。
And I walked past her, and this voice in my head kept saying, turn around to look at her breasts. Turn around, turn around, turn around. And my feminist female background kept saying, don't you dare, you pig. Don't turn around. And you know, I fought myself for a whole block, and then I turned around and checked her out.
我从她身边走过，头脑里的这个声音一直在说，回头看看她的胸部。回头，回头，回头。而我女权主义的女性背景一直在说，你这头猪，别回头。你知道，我和自己斗争了一整条街，然后我还是回头看了她一眼。
And before, it was cool. When I would do a poetry reading, I would get up and I would read these poems about, you know, women on the street. And I was a butch dyke, and that was very, very cutting edge, and that was very sexy and raw. And now I'm just a jerk. You know?
以前，这很酷。当我做诗歌朗诵时，我会站起来朗诵这些关于……你知道，街上女性的诗。那时我是个硬汉拉拉，那非常非常前卫，那非常性感且原始。而现在我只是个混蛋。你知道吗？
[BOTH LAUGH]
[两人大笑]
And then Alex's final question, when they talk-- you know, when Alex is, um--
然后是亚历克斯的最后一个问题，当他们谈论……你知道，当亚历克斯……
I know exactly. I know it so well because it's one of my favorite ever posed on our show.
我很清楚。我太了解它了，因为这是我在我们节目中提出的最喜欢的问题之一。
I know.
我知道。
Are there other ways that you feel like testosterone has altered the way you feel or perceive?
还有其他方式让你觉得睾酮改变了你的感受或认知吗？
Something that happened after I started taking testosterone-- I became interested in science. I was never interested in science before.
在我开始服用睾酮后发生的一件事——我对科学产生了兴趣。我以前从未对科学感兴趣过。
No way. Come on, are you serious? [LAUGHS]
没门。得了吧，你是认真的吗？[笑]
I'm serious. I'm serious.
我是认真的。我是认真的。
You're just setting us back 100 years, sir.
先生，你让我们退步了100年。
I know I am. I know--
我知道我退步了。我知道……
[BOTH LAUGH]
[两人大笑]
Both Julie and another producer on the radio show, Robyn Semien, surprised me by choosing as one of their favorites this interview that we have never replayed from an episode we have never rerun. This hasn't aired since September 2005. This is the show that we did immediately after Hurricane Katrina hit New Orleans. And what they each wanted to play was the same interview from that show. It was an interview with this woman named Denise Moore.
朱莉和电台的另一位制作人罗宾·塞米恩都让我感到惊讶，她们选择了我最喜欢的节目之一，那是我们从未重播过的采访，出自我们从未重播过的一期节目。自 2005 年 9 月以来，这期节目就再没播出过。这是卡特里娜飓风袭击新奥尔良后我们立即制作的节目。她们每个人都想播放那期节目中同一个采访。那是对一位名叫丹尼斯·摩尔的女性的采访。
Denise Moore had stayed behind in New Orleans with her mom, who was a nurse at Memorial Hospital. She was essential personnel, so she had to stay. And her mom asked Denise to stay with her, and also her niece and her niece's two-year-old.
丹尼斯·摩尔留在了新奥尔良，照顾她的妈妈，她妈妈是纪念医院的一名护士。她是重要人员，所以她必须留下。她妈妈要求丹尼斯和她待在一起，还有她的侄女以及侄女的两岁孩子。
And in this interview, Denise just tells me what happened to them over the course of the first few days after the hurricane. Here's Robyn talking about that interview. She heard this on the radio. She wasn't on staff back then.
在这次采访中，丹尼斯向我讲述了飓风发生后的最初几天她们身上发生了什么。这是罗宾谈论那次采访。她是在电台上听到这一期的。她当时还没加入我们的团队。
The shock to my system that happened, listening to that, was so severe that it's one of those shows where I remember exactly where I was. And it's everything that you've heard on the news so far up until that point. I mean, this was kind of Katrina, wall-to-wall media coverage about the Superdome and the convention center.
听那期节目时我受到的冲击太严重了，那是我记得清清楚楚我在哪里的节目之一。它包含了到那个时候为止你在新闻中听到的所有内容。我是说，这基本上是卡特里娜飓风的全方位媒体报道，关于超级巨蛋和会展中心。
But just hearing it, I didn't have a way to really let it affect me until I heard one woman's experience, and to let her kind of lay out exactly what was going on. I mean, I don't think I fully realized how desperate I was at the time to have something make sense until I heard this.
但仅仅是听到它，我直到听到一个女性的经历，让她把正在发生的事情原原本本地说出来，我才真正感受到它对我的影响。我是说，我不认为我当时完全意识到，在听到这个之前，我有多么渴望让某件事变得合理。
I remember when we put that show together, we all knew that there had already been lots of coverage of Katrina everywhere. And we thought the one thing that we could do was that till then, when you heard from people in New Orleans in the news, it was mostly in tiny little soundbites. And we thought the one contribution we could make was just let people talk longer. You know, it's easier to connect emotionally when you hear more.
我记得当我们制作那期节目时，我们都知道到处都有大量关于卡特里娜飓风的报道。我们认为我们可以做的一件事是，在那之前，当你在新闻中听到新奥尔良人的声音时，大多数都是非常简短的片段。我们认为我们可以做出的贡献就是让人们多说一会儿。你知道，当你听到更多内容时，情感上的联系更容易建立。
And so Denise is one of the interviews where this happens. And what happened to Denise after the flood is the hospital where her mom works at, she stays there for a couple days, then it gets shut down. And then everyone is ordered to move to the convention center, where they're told that there'll be buses to take them to safety out of the city. So they go.
所以丹尼斯就是发生这种情况的采访之一。洪水过后丹尼斯遭遇的是，她妈妈工作的医院，她在那里待了几天，然后被关闭了。然后所有人被命令转移到会展中心，在那里他们被告知会有大巴将他们带到城外的安全地带。于是他们去了。
And when we arrived, there were people all over the street, under the bridge. And we're like, why are these people on the street? Why aren't they in the convention center? And when we got there, people were saying, you don't want to go in there.
当我们到达时，到处都是人，在桥下。我们想，为什么这些人会在街上？为什么他们不在会展中心？当我们到达那里时，人们说，你不想进去。
Did you go inside at all?
你有进去过吗？
Not until the next day.
直到第二天。
What'd you see?
你看到了什么？
Inside?
里面吗？
Yeah.
是的。
A sewer. A sewer, literally. Stepping in feces, stepping in urine, all over the carpet. And people were sitting close as they could to the doors, but the smell was overwhelming.
一个下水道。字面意义上的下水道。踩在粪便里，踩在尿液里，地毯上到处都是。人们尽可能地靠近门口坐着，但那种气味令人窒息。
So then what do you do? Like what's the best you can do?
那么你做了什么？我是说，你所能做的最好的事情是什么？
I actually stopped eating the minute we got there. I wouldn't eat or drink anything. 'Cause I figured if you don't put nothing in, nothing's coming out. I was in the Army. But even at that, I still had to use the bathroom. It was ridiculous.
我实际上在到达那一刻就停止进食了。我什么都不吃也不喝。因为我想如果你不往里进东西，就不会有东西出来。我曾在军队待过。但即使这样，我还是得用洗手间。那真是太荒谬了。
And where'd you all sleep?
你们都睡在哪？
We slept on the sidewalk. And then what my mom wanted me to make sure I tell you, what they kept doing the whole time, was tell us to line up for the buses that never came. It was like they were doing drills every four hours.
我们睡在人行道上。然后我妈妈想让我确保告诉你的是，他们一直做的一件事，就是让我们排队等那些永远不会来的大巴。就像他们每四个小时进行一次演习一样。
You all have to line up for the bus. And if you bum-rush the bus, they're just going to take off without you, and nobody's going to get to go anywhere. You have to line up. You have to be in a straight line. We're talking about old people in wheelchairs and women with babies, in lines waiting for buses that you know goddamn well aren't coming. Like they were playing with us.
你们必须排队上车。如果你冲向大巴，他们就会直接丢下你们开走，没人能去任何地方。你必须排队。你必须站成一条直线。我们在谈论坐在轮椅上的老人和抱着婴儿的妇女，排队等着他们心知肚明根本不会来的大巴。就好像他们在耍弄我们。
And then the story became, they left us here to die. They're going to kill us.
然后故事变成了，他们把我们留在这里等死。他们要杀了我们。
You mean that's what people were saying to each other?
你是说这是人们在互相说的话？
Yeah.
是的。
And is that what you believed?
那这是你相信的吗？
I was almost convinced.
我几乎确信了。
That basically--
也就是说……
'Cause I kept having a vision of them opening that floodgate on us, of my niece and her baby floating away from me, screaming. And I just knew it. And then the next morning, I heard from somebody that they actually were going to open that floodgate. So by the time the rumors started that the National Guard was going to kill us, I almost halfway believed it.
因为我一直有个幻觉，他们会打开闸门淹死我们，我的侄女和她的孩子会从我身边飘走，尖叫着。我就是知道。然后第二天早上，我从某人那里听说他们真的要打开闸门。所以当关于国民警卫队要杀了我们的谣言开始时，我几乎半信半疑了。
And so people were saying, basically, they just brought us here. They're going to leave us here to die?
所以人们基本上在说，他们把我们带到这儿，就是为了把我们留在这儿等死？
Yeah. That's what we thought. The police kept passing us by. And the National Guard kept passing us by, with their guns pointed at us.
是的。我们就是这么想的。警察不断地从我们身边经过。国民警卫队也不断地经过，枪口对着我们。
And because they wouldn't-- when you see a truck full of water and people have been crying for water for a day and a night, and the water truck passes you by? Just keeps going? How are we supposed to believe these people were here to help us? It was almost like they were taunting us. And then don't forget, they kept lining us up for buses that never showed up.
因为他们就是不……当你看到一辆装满水的卡车，而人们已经为水哭喊了一天一夜，但水车却从你身边经过？只是不停地走？我们怎么可能相信这些人是来帮助我们的？那简直就像是在嘲弄我们。而且别忘了，他们一直让我们为永远不会出现的大巴排队。
Yeah.
是的。
We thought they were playing with us. And that best-case scenario. And the worst-case scenario, they want us to either kill each other or die. [LAUGHS INCREDULOUSLY] Or they were going to kill us.
我们以为他们在耍弄我们。这还是最好的情况。最坏的情况是，他们要么想让我们自相残杀，要么让我们去死。[难以置信地笑] 或者他们要杀了我们。
Why didn't people just walk away? That's what I don't understand. Couldn't you just--
为什么人们不走开呢？我不明白这一点。你们难道不能只是……
We weren't allowed. The police-- people kept trying to go up the bridge so they could go to Algiers, and they'd be turned away. And they'd be sent back down.
我们不被允许。警察……人们一直试图走上大桥去阿尔及尔，但他们被拦回来了。他们被赶回了下面。
And literally, they would just, like, go a couple streets away and somebody would send them back?
字面意思上，他们只要走开几条街，就有人把他们赶回来？
They'd go up the bridge to go across to the west bank, where it was dry.
他们走上大桥去往西岸，那里是干燥的。
Right.
对。
And lights were on, you know? And the National Guard was up there with guns. They turned them back with guns. And the governor gave orders to shoot to kill. You couldn't get through them.
而且有灯光，你知道吗？国民警卫队带着枪在那儿。他们用枪把他们逼了回来。州长下令格杀勿论。你无法穿过他们。
Yeah.
是的。
So people in groups would go up the bridge, trying to get across the river. People who had family across the river couldn't get across the river. They were not letting us out of there. They wasn't letting nobody in. So we were trapped. I can't even express it.
所以人们分组走上桥，试图穿过河流。那些在河对岸有家人的人无法过去。他们不让我们离开。他们不让任何人进去。所以我们被困住了。我甚至无法表达那种感觉。
Yeah.
是的。
I guess someday it'll calm down, and I'll be able to just cry like a normal person. But I feel like if I started crying now, I'd never stop.
我想总有一天心情会平复，我能像个正常人一样大哭一场。但我感觉如果我现在开始哭，我就永远停不下来了。
That was Denise Moore in 2005. The next producer we have is Nancy Updike. Nancy is the only person other than me who's working here now at the show who was actually here at the very beginning of the program. She moved to Chicago, and then a week later, we did our first episode.
那是 2005 年的丹尼斯·摩尔。下一位制作人是南希·厄普代克。除了我之外，南希是目前唯一一个在节目刚开始时就在这里的人。她搬到了芝加哥，一周后，我们就制作了第一期节目。
And what did you want to hear on today's show?
你想在今天的节目中听到什么？
I want to hear John Hodgman's story, from "The Real Story." Do you remember this?
我想听约翰·霍奇曼的故事，来自《真实的故事》。你还记得这个吗？
I think about this story all the time because the beginning of it is so beautiful.
我无时无刻不在想这个故事，因为它的开头太美了。
It's-- I mean, I think it's one of the best pieces of writing that's ever been on the show. It's so inviting and funny, and it keeps making these turns.
我是说，我认为这是节目中有史以来最好的作品之一。它非常吸引人且有趣，而且它不断地做出这些转折。
OK, so looking this up on our website, this is Episode 232, February 2003. Let's hear that.
好的，在我们的网站上查了一下，这是第 232 期，2003 年 2 月。让我们听听那个。
Here is something I'm not quick to admit, even to close friends-- never mind on the radio. Every day for the past several years, I have been working on a screenplay. This, of course, is shameful on its face, but it gets worse-- believe me.
这是一件我不愿轻易承认的事情，即使对亲密朋友也不例外——更别提在电台上了。过去几年里，我每天都在写一个剧本。这当然在表面上是可耻的，但情况更糟——相信我。
Working on my screenplay has been very hard, because the story I'm telling is long and complex and important. It's also difficult because I'm not actually writing anything down. Until recently, I would only think about it, night after night, lying in bed, rewriting my screenplay in my head. And as this process tends to make me sleepy, I have actually not gotten very far.
写我的剧本一直非常困难，因为我讲的故事很长、很复杂而且很重要。这也困难，因为我实际上并没有写下任何东西。直到最近，我只是在夜复一夜躺在床上时思考它，在脑海中重写我的剧本。由于这个过程往往会让我昏昏欲睡，我实际上并没有取得多大进展。
I began my screenplay on May 19, 1999, a date that may resonate with some of you who may already guess at the other main challenge of my project, the one that lends it the extra measure of sad delusion and ultimate futility that accompanies the writing of any screenplay. And that is that my screenplay has already been written by someone else, and it is called Star Wars , Episode One , The Phantom Menace.
我于 1999 年 5 月 19 日开始了我的剧本，这个日期可能会引起你们中一些人的共鸣，你们可能已经猜到了我项目的另一个主要挑战，那个赋予它额外的悲伤妄想和最终徒劳的挑战，而这伴随着任何剧本的写作。那就是我的剧本已经被别人写过了，名字叫《星球大战前传：魅影危机》。
[MUSIC - " STAR WARS THEME"]
[音乐 - 《星球大战主题曲》]
It's perfect.
太完美了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
It's perfect. And then the whole essay, it makes this incredible turn at the end to his mom dying. And that's why he's been obsessively rewriting The Phantom Menace in his head, that he's turning away from this terrible thing that's happening.
太完美了。而且整篇随笔在结尾做了一个不可思议的转折，谈到了他母亲的去世。这就是为什么他一直在脑海中痴迷地重写《魅影危机》，他在逃避这个正在发生的极其糟糕的事情。
Nancy Updike, talking about John Hodgman's writing. When I sat down in the studio with Sarah Koenig to talk about her favorite moments to play on the show today, her favorites included some of Nancy's writing. And just to introduce Sarah, she's been here at the show for nearly a decade. She's reported lots of stories.
南希·厄普代克，谈论约翰·霍奇曼的文字。当我和莎拉·凯尼格坐在录音室里讨论今天在节目中播放她最喜欢的时刻时，她最喜欢的内容包括南希的一些文字。为了介绍莎拉，她在节目中已经工作了近十年。她报道过很多故事。
She's filled in as host now and then, most recently of the "Coincidences" show. And she brought a whole list of favorites into the studio. And she said some of Nancy's writing has just stayed with her.
她偶尔会担任主持人，最近的一次是《巧合》那一期。她带来了一长串最喜欢的清单。她说南希的一些文字一直留在她的脑海里。
Do you remember all that nice writing, and I was listening to, "I'm From the Private Sector and I'm Here to Help," when she went to Iraq.
你还记得所有那些优美的文字吗，我当时在听《我来自私营部门，我来提供帮助》，那是她去伊拉克的时候。
There's a passage about-- are you going to talk about the passage about that one guy who's leading the--
有一段关于……你要谈论那段关于那个领导……的家伙的描写吗？
Hank.
汉克。
Hank. Where she describes Hank.
汉克。她描述汉克的那段。
Yeah, that whole opening thing with Hank, she has this light touch, and it's funny. And you immediately feel like, oh, I know who this guy is. So this is show number 266. It's from, I think, 2005. 2004, maybe.
是的，关于汉克的那整个开场，她有一种轻盈的笔触，很有趣。你会立刻觉得，哦，我知道这家伙是谁。所以这是第 266 期节目。我想是 2005 年的。或者是 2004 年。
It's 2004. It's June 2004. And it's pretty early in the coverage of the private contractors in Iraq.
是 2004 年。2004 年 6 月。在伊拉克私营承包商的报道中还算是很早期的。
Right. And one of the companies she focused on was this security company called Custer Battles. And it turned out that they were kind of in some trouble. And so she just hangs out with Hank for a while.
对。她关注的公司之一是这家名为“卡斯特战斗”的安全公司。结果他们遇到了一些麻烦。所以她就和汉克待了一段时间。
Hank is the man who was brought in to clean up Custer Battles' PSD operation. Hank has a vision for the kind of men he wants working for him.
汉克是被带进来清理“卡斯特战斗”PSD（个人安全保卫）行动的人。汉克对他想雇佣的人有一种愿景。
Steely-eyed, flat-bellied professionals.
眼神坚毅、肚子平坦的专业人士。
It's possible Hank came up with this description by looking in the mirror. He's a 49-year-old man with small blue eyes, a former paratrooper and ranger. The son of a decorated soldier. Married to the daughter of a soldier. Father of two soldiers, one of whom was in Iraq and is now in Afghanistan on a mission he can't talk about.
汉克提出这个描述很可能是通过照镜子。他是一个 49 岁的男人，有着小小的蓝色眼睛，一名前伞兵和游骑兵。一个功勋卓著的士兵的儿子。娶了一个士兵的女儿。两个士兵的父亲，其中一个在伊拉克，现在在阿富汗执行一项他不能说的任务。
Hank is cryptic. He doesn't want me to use his last name. He won't even tell me what rank he achieved. I looked it up later-- lieutenant colonel.
汉克很神秘。他不想让我用他的姓。他甚至不肯告诉我他达到了什么军衔。我后来查了——中校。
He's done private security work overseas before. He won't give details, of course. But he will-- and this is the thing about Hank-- he will poke fun at it.
他以前在海外做过私人安全工作。当然，他不会提供细节。但他会——这就是汉克的地方——他会对此开玩笑。
So you gotta get the look, the security guy look. Serious, I'm dead serious about this business. I'm steely-eyed and I'm scanning the horizon constantly. And usually when you go to-- like if I go to Africa or someplace like that, and you're on some kind of security mission, it takes you about two seconds to get off the plane, look around, and say, oh, there's somebody else on a mission.
所以你得做出那个样子，安全人员的样子。严肃，我对这个生意非常认真。我眼神坚毅，并且不断地扫描地平线。通常当你去……比如如果我去非洲或者类似的地方，你在执行某种安全任务时，你下飞机大约两秒钟就能环顾四周，然后说，噢，还有其他人在执行任务。
And you kind of sidle up to them, and you go, SAS? And they nod, and then they go, Rangers? And you go-- you kind of nod. And then finally you ask, who are you working for? Of course, he can't tell. He asks you, and you can't tell.
然后你就会凑近他们，说，SAS（特种空勤团）？他们点点头，然后他们问，游骑兵？你就会……你点点头。最后你问，你在为谁工作？当然，他不能说。他问你，你也不能说。
And then you-- [LAUGHS] And then you wander off, you see? But you had that initial, like dogs sniffing each other, you do. But it's very easy to pick the guys out. They all got the look.
然后你……[笑] 然后你就走开了，明白吗？但你们有那种初步的，像狗互相嗅闻一样的感觉，确实有。但要挑出这些人非常容易。他们都有那个样子。
So he wants his PSD guys to have the look.
所以他希望他的 PSD 队员有那个样子。
Steely-eyed, flat-bellied professionals.
眼神坚毅、肚子平坦的专业人士。
And he walks around doing that look. But he also knows it's all a bit of a put-on. A man dance, as he calls it. And with tens of thousands of American military and ex-military and private military in Iraq right now, it's very possible that we are standing in the middle of the largest man dance on the planet.
他四处走动时都带着那个样子。但他也知道这有点像表演。他称之为“男人舞”。随着现在伊拉克有数以万计的美国军队、退役军人和私营军事人员，很有可能我们正站在地球上最大的“男人舞”中间。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
OK, so what else you got?
好的，还有什么？
I have to say, this story, the one I'm going to pick right now, is the one, sort of, if people don't know the show, this is the one where I'm like, just listen to this one. It's from 2007. It's "Duty Calls." It's Josh Bearman's story about his family.
我必须说，这个故事，我现在要选的这个，如果人们不了解这个节目，这就是我会说：只听这一个。它来自 2007 年的《职责召唤》。这是乔什·贝尔曼关于他家庭的故事。
Oh yeah, that's a really beautiful story.
噢对，那是个非常美丽的故事。
And it's so deftly done, in this way where if you really think about what the story's about-- it's like in someone else's hands, it could just be this cliche of like, oh, you know, my mom's an alcoholic and my brother's a screw-up. And all the cliches that could go along with that. And you know who these people are.
它处理得非常巧妙，如果你仔细思考这个故事的内容的话——它在别人手中，可能会变成那种陈词滥调，比如，“噢，我妈是个酒鬼，我兄弟是个混蛋”。以及随之而来的所有陈词滥调。你很了解这些人。
And then you listen to his and you realize, like, no, you don't know. And it's so compelling. And everyone in it, it turns out to be so likable, you know? You sort of-- and that's, I feel like, in a way, the surprise of the story, which is also super raw in parts.
然后你听他的故事，你会意识到，不，你不了解。而且它非常引人入胜。故事里的每个人，最后看起来都非常讨人喜欢，你知道吗？你有点……我觉得在某种程度上，这正是故事的惊喜所在，而且在某些部分非常原始。
Which part should we play?
我们应该播放哪一段？
I don't know. The scene that really got me is when he talks to his-- it's a conversation between Josh and his mom. And it starts at 19:07. Are you on the thing?
不知道。真正触动我的是当他和他妈对话的那一幕……那是乔什和他妈妈之间的对话。从 19 分 07 秒开始。你准备好了吗？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
If you start it at 19:07, where they just have this conversation, and so much is happening in the course of this conversation, where like, he's sort of angry and she gets kind of defensive. And then she sort of says this really honest thing that makes you understand how she's been feeling all this time.
如果你从 19 分 07 秒开始，他们在那儿进行对话，这段对话过程中发生了很多事情，他有点生气，她变得有点防御。然后她说了那句非常诚实的话，让你理解她这段时间以来的感受。
Yeah, OK, so this is episode 334, from June of 2007.
好的，这是 2007 年 6 月的第 334 期节目。
Take, for example, the hurricane that hit Florida months before the paramedics came for my mom. As the Category 5 storm was making landfall, David decided to go for a drive. He was pulled over by the cops, which wasn't that surprising since the car had no registration, no insurance, no working taillights, and a cracked windshield. David, who had no license-- and maybe had taken some pills to boot-- had been pulled over twice already for having that car on the road. He was thrown in jail for a week, and my mother was left all alone.
以几个月前袭击佛罗里达的飓风为例，那是急救人员来接我妈妈之前。当五级风暴即将来临时，戴维决定去开车。他被警察拦下了，这并不令人惊讶，因为车没有登记、没有保险、没有工作的尾灯，还有一个破裂的挡风玻璃。没有驾照的戴维——甚至可能还嗑了药——因为把那辆车开上路已经被拦下两次了。他被关进监狱一周，我母亲被单独留了下来。
I mean, I was sitting here in total darkness. I mean, there weren't even any streetlights on. You know, water's falling down. Everything was so chaotic. And then, of course, I started drinking out of control, and that was, you know-- it just started out saying, I just want a little relief from this insanity, and it made me even more insane.
我是说，我当时坐在黑暗中。我是说，甚至连路灯都没有。你知道，水倾泻而下。一切都那么混乱。然后，当然，我开始失控地喝酒，那是，你知道……它刚开始说，我只是想从这种疯狂中得到一点解脱，但它让我变得更加疯狂。
How come you didn't call me during that whole period?
那段时间你怎么没给我打电话？
Maybe because I really didn't know what to say, Josh.
也许是因为我真的不知道说什么，乔什。
Well, I wish I'd have known to come down. I mean, that's-- you know, and then especially as it got worse, I mean, I wish somebody had called, and--
好吧，我希望当时知道要下去看看。我是说，那是……你知道，特别是当情况变得更糟时，我是说，我希望有人打了电话，然后……
Yeah, I know.
是的，我知道。
Ethan or I could have come out.
伊森或者我可以过去。
Yeah. Yeah, I understand that, Josh. But it's just, like-- [SIGHS]
是的。是的，我理解，乔什。但这只是……[叹气]
And I'm not-- I wasn't saying that to make you feel guilty about not calling me. I was just--
我不是……我没说那是为了让你因为没打电话给我而感到内疚。我只是……
(TEARFULLY)  No, it's hard to explain. It's just, like, you know, you just don't want to intrude into your and Ethan's life and say, one more time, one more time, one more time.
（含泪）不，很难解释。这只是，你知道，你就是不想闯入你和伊森的生活，一次又一次，一次又一次地说。
Well, I wouldn't have minded.
好吧，我不会介意的。
Well, I didn't know about it.
好吧，我当时不知道。
I would rather have done that than wind up down here for four months.
我宁愿那样做，也不愿最后在那儿待了四个月。
Yeah, I know that. It's part of the whole cycle, is that you don't-- you don't want to tell anybody else, because when you tell somebody else, then you have to-- you're telling yourself. Which is the last thing you want to do.
是的，我知道。这是整个循环的一部分，就是你不想……你不想告诉任何人，因为当你告诉别人时，你就必须……你是在告诉你自己。而这是你最不想做的事。
Isn't that good?
这不好吗？
Yeah. OK, so what else you got?
是的。好的，还有什么？
So there's one-- I don't know if it's too weirdly self-referential or sycophantic or something. But there's this really nice moment of you and Tami Sagher that I came across. It's not one that's in my pantheon at all, but just as I was looking back at old stories, I was like, oh, what's this one? And I listened back.
还有一件事……我不知道这是否太奇怪地自省或奉承什么的。但有一个你和塔米·萨格的非常好的时刻，我偶然发现了。它根本不在我的必选清单里，但就在我回顾旧故事时，我心想，哦，这是哪一个？我就回去听了。
And I realized some of the things I like best on the show are when you're just interviewing someone, and you get a little off-topic, and suddenly something really revealing happens. I feel like it happens kind of a lot when you're interviewing people. And I don't know. You say stuff in interviews that I find really surprising.
我意识到，在节目中我最喜欢的一些时刻，是你采访某人时，话题稍微跑偏了，突然发生了一些非常揭露性的事情。我觉得这在你采访别人时发生得挺多的。我不知道。你在采访中说的话让我感到非常惊讶。
And so anyway, there's this nice moment in-- I think it's show 314. It's a show called "It's Never Over." And it's the last act. And it's just this interview with Tami Sagher about this joke that she'd thought up like four years earlier and never deployed, because it was a topical joke about Ralph Nader. And then this opportunity comes for her to deploy this joke.
总之，在……我想是第 314 期节目中有一个很棒的时刻。那是一期叫《永不结束》的节目。是最后一个部分。就是关于塔米·萨格对她四年前想出但从未用过的一个笑话的采访，因为那是一个关于拉尔夫·内德的时事笑话。然后她有了机会去用这个笑话。
Tami Sagher, I should say, is a comedy writer, and she was deploying this joke in a room full of writers at her brand new job.
塔米·萨格，我应该说，是一位喜剧作家，她在她新工作的编剧室里使用了这个笑话。
And she just nails it, and everyone thinks it's this off-the-cuff hilarious comment, not knowing that she'd been saving it up for all this time. And it, like, gets teed up for her perfectly, and she just, like, lets it off really casually, and everybody laughs.
她简直说得太棒了，所有人都认为这是一个脱口而出的搞笑评论，并不知道她已经存了这么久。有人完美地为她铺垫好了，她就这样轻描淡写地说了出来，大家都笑了。
And there's this moment right after that where the anecdote has been told. She has the slightly larger thought, like you'd think, done. And then it keeps going, and it's good. And that's at-- I don't know if you want to play it, but that's at 50:22 of that show.
在那之后有一个时刻，轶事讲完了。她有了一个稍微深一点的想法，就像你认为的那样，结束了。然后它继续进行，效果很好。那是在……我不知道你想不想放，那是在那期节目的 50 分 22 秒。
Hold on.
等等。
And so are you done? Are you in? Is that it? Like you used that joke to kind of get you over the hump, and now is it through?
所以你做完了吗？你进去了吗？就这样吗？就像你利用那个笑话来帮助你度过难关，现在结束了吗？
Um, I felt like I'm more in, yeah. I don't know that I'll ever feel like I'm in with everybody. [LAUGHS] But no, I have felt like I'm more in. I have felt a marked difference. I mean, do you ever feel like you're totally in with anybody?
嗯，我觉得我更融入了，是的。我不知道我是否会觉得自己和每个人都真正融入了。[笑] 但不，我确实觉得我更融入了。我感觉到了明显的不同。我是说，你有没有觉得你和任何人完全融入过？
Dude, I'm married to somebody who I feel like I'm constantly in a situation of having-- I feel like-- and she doesn't feel this way, but I totally feel like every day I have to prove myself anew.
伙计，我和一个我感觉一直在这种境况中的人结婚了……我觉得……虽然她不这么觉得，但我完全觉得我每天都必须重新证明自己。
Really? Well, here's one more thing, though, that is kind of sucky about it, though, is by constantly checking in with what the other person's opinion of you is, you're not just being with that person. There's a level of removal there that is sad.
真的吗？好吧，这里还有一件事，虽然关于这一点很烂，就是通过不断查看对方对你的看法，你就不再只是和那个人在一起了。这中间有一层疏离感，很悲伤。
Totally. That's totally my personality. For me, I think that something went wrong when I was a kid, where I think that other people, they just accept that they're in. They accept that this other person likes them, and they don't have to keep proving themself.
完全正确。那完全是我的性格。对我来说，我认为当我还是个孩子时有些事情出了错，我认为其他人，他们只是接受了他们已经融入的事实。他们接受了对方喜欢他们，而不需要继续证明自己。
Whereas for me, it's entirely temporal. I'm constantly judging the whole thing moment by moment. And it could always fall apart. For me, it never ends.
而对我来说，这是完全暂时的。我不断地逐秒评估整件事。而且它随时可能崩溃。对我来说，它永不结束。
I remember when I was a kid, and I think I was probably like four?
我记得当我还是个孩子时，我想我大概四岁？
So wait, so that thing that I say, that's the thing?
等等，所以我说的那件事，就是那件事？
That's the thing.
就是那件事。
Yeah. God, I totally did not remember saying that until just now. Yeah, that's so true of me.
是的。天哪，直到刚才我完全不记得我说了那些话。是的，那对我来说太真实了。
It's so personal. And I feel like it's really-- I don't know. Like I've known you for 10 years now, right? And I heard you say that.  I was like, oh, right. That's right. Because I was like, I know there's a lot of times in interviews where I've just been listening in, and you'll reveal this thing, and I'm always just like, that's ballsy.
这太个人化了。我觉得这真的……我不知道。就像我认识你十年了，对吧？我听到你这么说。我就心想，哦，对了。那是对的。因为我心想，我知道很多采访中我只是在听，而你会揭露这一点，我总是心想，那真有胆量。
To me that's just so obvious that you would do that if you have something like that to do, because it's good tape. Like your job is to make good tape. You know what I mean? Like that's our job, is to make good tape.
对我来说，如果你有那样的事情要做，你会那样做简直太明显了，因为这是好的录音。就像你的工作是做出好的录音。你懂我的意思吗？就像那是我们的工作，做出好的录音。
I know, but I feel like that's the thing that's different, right? Like you're willing to kind of exploit anything you've got in there. And I think a lot of people, for a lot of people, that stuff is just off-limits.
我知道，但我认为这就是不同之处，对吧？你愿意去挖掘你内在的任何东西。我认为很多人，对很多人来说，那些东西是禁区。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Sarah Koenig. Coming up, me and Bruce Banner, so similar. And more favorites from the past 499 episodes. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, saying this now for the 500th time, when our program continues.
莎拉·凯尼格。接下来，我和布鲁斯·班纳，如此相似。以及过去 499 期节目中更多最喜欢的片段。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共电台和公共广播国际公司，现在第 500 次说这句话，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. It is our 500th episode. We're spending it by having the producers of the program come into the studio and pick their favorite moments from the last 17 and 1/2 years of shows. God, it sounds like so many.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们的第 500 期节目。我们正在通过让节目的制作人走进录音室，挑选过去 17 年半节目中他们最喜欢的时刻来度过它。天哪，听起来真是太多了。
Well, four of the producers of the show, when they came in to talk about the favorites, they said they thought of all the possible stories they could play today, the story that meant the most to them was the one when they first heard our show or first noticed it doing something different from other radio shows.
嗯，节目的四位制作人在进来谈论最喜欢的时刻时，他们说他们想到了今天能放的所有可能的故事，对他们意义最大的故事是他们第一次听到我们的节目，或者第一次注意到它在做一些与其他电台节目不同的事情时的那个故事。
For me, it was sort of like, what-- what is this thing?
对我来说，当时就像是，什么……这到底是什么玩意儿？
That's Jonathan Goldstein. He was a producer on the show for a few years, and he's continued to do stories for us since. Longtime listeners may remember the story of the phone message, "You and the Little Mermaid can go eff yourselves." Anyway, he's now the host of the Public Radio show and podcast called WireTap. And he said this about his first time hearing our show.
那是乔纳森·戈德斯坦。他在节目中做了几年制作人，此后一直为我们做故事。长期的听众可能还记得那个电话留言的故事，“你和那个小美人鱼去死吧。”总之，他现在是公共电台节目和播客《窃听》的主持人。他这样描述他第一次听我们节目的经历。
There was a particular kind of mood to it, and it just-- it really, it sucked me in. You know which one I'm talking about?
它有一种特别的情绪，它就……它真的，把我吸进去了。你知道我说的是哪一个吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不知道。
It's the top, the prologue, to "The Cruelty of Children."
是《儿童的残酷》的开头，序幕。
Oh, that's so interesting. No one has mentioned that one at all, and that's totally a favorite of mine.
噢，那真有意思。根本没有人提到过那个，那绝对是我的最爱。
Really? Well, OK, so I haven't heard it in years. And so I was surprised by a couple things. One, that it was two minutes long.
真的吗？好吧，所以我有几年没听过了。所以有几件事让我感到惊讶。第一，它有两分钟长。
Wow, is that true? It's that fast?
哇，是真的吗？有那么快吗？
Yeah. And it's so funny, because in my memory, it was like half the show or something, which is insane. And you come on and you're saying, I was talking to a first-grader about libraries--
是的。这太有趣了，因为在我的记忆中，它占了节目的一半左右，那太疯狂了。然后你上来说，我在和一个一年级学生谈论图书馆——
I was talking to a first-grader about libraries.
我在和一个一年级学生谈论图书馆。
Then I suddenly found myself talking about bullies.
然后我突然发现自己在谈论恶霸。
And I suddenly found myself talking about bullies. That's the thing about the idea of bullies. The idea is so powerful that it can derail any conversation and pull it towards its own orbit.
然后我突然发现自己在谈论恶霸。这就是关于恶霸这个想法的事情。这个想法太强大了，它能打乱任何对话，并将它拉向它自己的轨道。
Here's how it happened. We were on a school bus. I was asking the first-grader what kinds of books he takes out from the library.
它是这样发生的。我们在校车上。我正在问那个一年级学生他从图书馆借什么书。
Like I couldn't even wrap my head around it. Like, I didn't even understand. Like who is this guy? Why is he talking to a first-grader in the first place? You know what I mean?
就像我甚至无法理解它。就像，我甚至不明白。这家伙是谁？他为什么要在第一时间和一个一年级学生谈话？你懂我的意思吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like, why are you-- like were you out for coffee? Are there six-year-olds in your social circle? And because it was like my first glimpse into the world of the show, my sense of it was, here's this guy who's this kind of like wandering America, like the Incredible Hulk or something. Like with his jacket slung over his shoulder down a highway with his microphone out, looking for company and taking it wherever he can get it. Whether it's in a roadside coffee shop or on a school bus talking to a six-year-old.
就像，你为什么……你是出来喝咖啡的吗？你的社交圈里有六岁小孩吗？因为它是我对这个节目的第一瞥，我的感觉是，这就是这家伙，他就像是在漫游美国的绿巨人或者类似的东西。带着他的夹克搭在肩膀上，沿着高速公路，麦克风伸出来，寻找伙伴，无论在哪里都能找到。不管是在路边的咖啡馆还是在校车上和六岁小孩谈话。
And that was all it took. Suddenly, he launches into this big thing.
那只需要那么多。突然间，他发起了一个大的话题。
This kid in our class, he's a bully and he takes out bully books. Takes out bully ones.
我们班的那个孩子，他是恶霸，他借恶霸书。借恶霸那样的。
Like what are the bully books?
什么是恶霸书？
They teach you how to be meaner, to push people around and stuff.
它们教你如何变得更刻薄，去欺负人之类的。
There are books to teach you how to be mean?
有教你如何变得刻薄的书？
Yeah. And nice. There's this one book that's called Bullies Are Made for Pushing Around , and Bullies Make All the Rules . And they be picking on nice kids.
是的。还有好人书。有一本书叫《恶霸就是为了欺负人而生的》，还有《恶霸制定所有规则》。他们一直在挑衅好孩子。
As far as I was able to determine later, talking with parents and teachers and consulting with books in print, there is no book-- [LAUGHS] There is no real book that corresponds to the book this first-grader thinks he saw the bully read.
据我后来与家长和老师交谈，并查阅了出版书籍，没有这样的一本书——[笑] 没有一本真正的书对应这个一年级学生认为他看到恶霸读过的那本书。
And you know, it's a shame. It was such a comforting thought. Why are people bullies? Why are they so mean? Why do they push you sometimes, and take your change, and say nasty things? Maybe they're just getting it from a book.
你知道，真可惜。那是一个多么令人安慰的想法。为什么人会成为恶霸？为什么他们那么刻薄？为什么他们有时欺负你，抢你的零钱，说些难听的话？也许他们只是从书里学来的。
I'm surprised-- are you sure that that's what the book was about? I can't believe somebody would write a book saying here's how to be mean to other people.
我很惊讶……你确定那是书的内容吗？我无法相信有人会写一本书说这里是如何对其他人刻薄的。
Well, maybe the person who wrote is was probably a bully himself.
嗯，也许写这本书的人本人就是一个恶霸。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Next up is Brian Reed. Brian is one of our newest staffers. He was an intern here. He's been a producer for a year and a half. Regular listeners may remember the story that he produced about Guatemala last year, and that guy who survived a massacre at a place called Dos Erres.
接下来是布莱恩·里德。布莱恩是我们最新的员工之一。他曾在这里实习。他做了一年半的制作人。常听的听众可能记得他去年制作的关于危地马拉的故事，还有那个在名为“Dos Erres”的地方大屠杀中幸存下来的家伙。
Anyway, the story that Brian wanted to play today was also the first story that he remembers hearing, though he did not hear this story on the radio. When he was in college, I came and spoke, and I played this story from the stage.
总之，布莱恩今天想播放的故事也是他记得听到的第一个故事，虽然他并没有在电台上听到这个故事。当他上大学时，我去演讲，我在台上播放了这个故事。
Yeah, and I think-- I mean, I knew what the show was, because clearly I went to see you. But I don't remember ever hearing the show before that. I don't have a memory of it.
是的，我想……我是说，我知道这个节目是什么，因为显然我去看你了。但我不记得在此之前听过这个节目。我没有关于它的记忆。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. And it's this little story that Jack Hitt told on the "Kid Logic" episode.
是的。这就是杰克·希特在《儿童逻辑》那一期里讲的小故事。
Well, it all began at Christmas two years ago, when my daughter was four years old. And it was the first time she had ever asked about, what did this holiday mean? And so I explained to her that this was celebrating the birth of Jesus.
好吧，这一切始于两年前的圣诞节，当时我女儿四岁。这是她第一次询问这个节日意味着什么。所以我向她解释说，这是为了庆祝耶稣的诞生。
And she wanted to know more about that. And we went out and bought a kid's Bible and had these readings at night. She loved them. Wanted to know everything about Jesus. So we read a lot about his birth and about his teaching.
她想了解更多。我们出去买了一本儿童圣经，晚上有这些读经活动。她很喜欢它们。想知道关于耶稣的一切。所以我们读了很多关于他的诞生和他的教导。
And she would ask constantly what that phrase was. And I would explain to her that it was "Do unto others as you would have them do unto you." Then we would talk about those old words and what that all meant, you know?
她会不断地问那个短语是什么。我会向她解释是“你们愿意人怎样待你们，你们也要怎样待人。”然后我们会谈论那些古老的词汇以及那意味着什么，你知道吗？
And then one day, we were driving past a big church, and out front was an enormous crucifix. She said, who is that? And I guess I'd never really told that part of the story. So I had to sort of-- yeah, oh, that's Jesus. And I forgot to tell you the ending, yeah.
然后有一天，我们开车经过一座大教堂，前面有一个巨大的十字架。她说，那是谁？我想我从来没真正讲过故事的那一部分。所以我不得不有点……噢，那是耶稣。我忘了告诉你结局了，是的。
Well, you know, he ran afoul of the Roman government. This message that he had was so radical and unnerving to the prevailing authorities of the time that they had to kill him. They came to the conclusion that he would have to die. That message was too troublesome.
好吧，你知道，他触犯了罗马政府。他带来的这个信息在当时太激进、太让当局不安了，他们不得不杀了他。他们得出结论，他必须死。那个信息太麻烦了。
It was about a month later after that Christmas, we'd gone through the whole story of what Christmas meant. And it was mid-January, and her preschool celebrates the same holidays as the local schools. So Martin Luther King Day was off. And so I knocked off work that day and I decided we'd play, and I'd take her out to lunch.
那是那个圣诞节大约一个月后，我们已经讲完了圣诞节意味着什么。那是 1 月中旬，她的幼儿园和当地学校放一样的假。所以马丁·路德·金纪念日放假。那天我没工作，决定带她出去吃午饭。
And we were sitting in there, and right on the table where we happened to plop down, was the Arts section of the local newspaper. And there, big as life, was a huge drawing by, like, a 10-year-old kid from the local schools of Martin Luther King. And she said, who's that?
我们坐在那里，就在我们碰巧坐下的桌子上，是当地报纸的艺术版。那里，就像真人一样大，有一个当地学校里大约 10 岁小孩画的一幅巨大的马丁·路德·金的画。她说，那是谁？
And I said, well, as it happens, that's Martin Luther King. And he's why you're not in school today, because we're celebrating his birthday. This is the day we celebrate his life.
我说，嗯，凑巧那是马丁·路德·金。这就是你今天不用上学的原因，因为我们在庆祝他的生日。这是我们庆祝他一生的日子。
And she said, so who was he? I said, well, he was a preacher. And she looks up at me and goes, (EXCITEDLY)  for Jesus?
她说，那他是谁？我说，嗯，他是一位牧师。她抬头看着我，说（兴奋地）为了耶稣？
And I said, yeah, yeah, actually he was. But there was another thing that he was really famous for, which is that he had a message. And you're trying to say this to a four-year-old. It's very-- this is the first time they ever hear anything, so you just very careful about how you phrase everything.
我说，是的，是的，实际上他是。但他还有另一件事非常出名，就是他有一个信息。你正试图对一个四岁孩子说这个。这非常……这是他们第一次听到任何东西，所以你对措辞非常小心。
So I said, you know, well, yeah, he was a preacher, and he had a message. And she said, what was his message? And I said, well, he said that you should treat everybody the same, no matter what they look like. And she thought about that for a minute. And she said, well, that's what Jesus said.
所以我说，你知道，嗯，是的，他是一位牧师，他有一个信息。她说，他的信息是什么？我说，嗯，他说你应该同样地对待每一个人，不管他们长什么样。她想了一会儿。她说，嗯，那就是耶稣说的。
And I said, yeah, I guess it is. I never thought of it that way, but yeah. And that is sort of like "Do unto others as you would have them do unto you." And she thought for a minute and looked up at me and said, did they kill him too?
我说，是的，我想是这样。我从没那样想过，但是的。那有点像“你们愿意人怎样待你们，你们也要怎样待人。”她想了一会儿，抬头看着我说，他们也杀了他吗？
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Jack Hitt. Alex Blumberg has been with our program on and off since 1997. He's one of the co-creators of Planet Money , the podcast and the website, which is a co-production of our show and NPR News. He created a [INAUDIBLE] of money with Adam Davidson, and Alex picked, as his pick for today, one of Adam's very first radio stories from 15 years ago.
杰克·希特。亚历克斯·布隆伯格自 1997 年起就断断续续地在我们的节目中工作。他是播客和网站《金钱星球》的联合创作者之一，这是我们节目和 NPR 新闻的联合制作。他与亚当·戴维森一起创造了一个……[听不清] 金钱，亚历克斯今天选择的是亚当 15 年前最早的一期电台故事之一。
It was on the show that we had called "How To." And the premise was that there's this group of people who calculate how much a human life is worth. And they're insurance adjusters. And Adam Davidson--
它在我们要做的名为《如何做》的节目中。前提是有这样一群人计算一个人值多少钱。他们是保险理赔员。亚当·戴维森……
And this is so if somebody dies in an accident or something, they can tell you how much you can get for that person's life?
所以如果是某人在事故中去世了，他们可以告诉你你可以为一个人的生命得到多少钱？
Yeah, for like a wrongful death suit. And insurance adjusters are sort of very familiar with this. And so Adam Davidson goes and basically asks the question, how much is my life worth now, and what could I do to make my life worth more if I wanted to?
是的，比如不正当死亡诉讼。而保险理赔员对这方面非常熟悉。所以亚当·戴维森去问了一个问题，我的生命现在值多少钱，如果我想让我的生命值更多钱，我能做什么？
Right, which is good premise. Like the premise is great.
对，这前提很好。前提很棒。
And that's exactly the type of premise that you would go out, and then it would just be quashed by reality. And you know, there's this thing that happens were you sort of say, like, here's what I think the story is going to be. And then what always happens is you go out, and you're like, aah, the actual story is way more complicated.
这正是那种你会走出去，然后它就会被现实粉碎的前提。你知道，有件事会发生，你会说，我觉得这个故事会是这样。然后总是会发生的事情是你出去了，你会觉得，啊，实际的故事要复杂得多。
Yeah, and it's not as good. It doesn't--
是的，而且没那么好。它不……
Not as good, and it's not as funny or outrageous or whatever you're thinking it will be.
没那么好，也没那么有趣或离谱，或者任何你想的那样。
The thing you hope for, it wasn't true.
你所希望的，并不是真的。
It wasn't this. And then at some point, the words "actuarial tables" are going to mentioned, and then you're screwed.
并不是这个。然后当“精算表”这几个字被提到时，你就完了。
No, no, no, yeah, and then people turn off the radio when they hear that.
不，不，不，是的，然后人们听到那个就关掉电台了。
Yeah, exactly. And this is the story where it's actually the opposite. Like you think it's going to be good, and then what actually happens is even better.
是的，完全正确。而这个故事实际上恰恰相反。你以为它会很好，然后实际上发生的甚至更好。
OK, so I'm just bringing this up on the computer. This to show number 94 from 1998.
好的，我正在电脑上调出这个。这是 1998 年的第 94 期节目。
It's like the first three minutes of it.
就像是前三分钟。
When I was seven, my mom told me about a guy who died because his car blew up. It was the manufacturer's fault, and the man's relatives sued and got about $300,000. I remember wondering about that number. I remember thinking, if you were going to assign a number to human life, it would have to be huge, at least a million. To my seven-year-old mind, a million seemed like the start of the really big numbers.
当我七岁时，我妈妈告诉我一个因为车子爆炸而死的人。那是制造商的错，那个人的亲属起诉并得到了大约 30 万美元。我记得想过那个数字。我记得在想，如果你要为一个生命分配一个数字，它必须非常巨大，至少一百万。在七岁的我看来，一百万似乎是真正大数字的开始。
The other day, I wanted to find out how much my life was worth, so I want to talk to this guy, George Karas, an adjuster in Merrillville, Indiana. He looked me over, asked me my stats-- age, job, marital status.
前几天，我想找出我的生命值多少钱，所以我去和这个家伙交谈，乔治·卡拉斯，印第安纳州梅里尔维尔的一名理赔员。他打量了我一下，问了我的统计数据——年龄、职业、婚姻状况。
Right now, today, I will pay you $35,000.
现在，今天，我会支付你 3 万美元。
For my death?
为了我的死亡？
For your death. Total.
为了你的死亡。总计。
That's crazy. I'm-- I'm worth more than--
这太疯狂了。我……我比这值钱……
What do you think it's worth?
你觉得它值多少钱？
And then it just gets better, because listen, they fight now about it.
然后它变得更好了，因为听着，他们现在为了这个争吵。
My life, worth less than half a second of one commercial on Seinfeld . George explains it this way. I'm single, got no dependents, and as far as he's concerned, no one would be all that affected by my death. I argued with him, pointed out my parents need me. I make them laugh. I tease them in a way that nobody else can.
我的生命，竟然比《宋飞传》里的一个商业广告的一半还少。乔治这样解释。我是单身，没有受抚养人，据他所知，没有人会受到我死亡的太大影响。我跟他争论，指出我父母需要我。我让他们笑。我以一种没人能做到的方式逗他们。
How often do they see you?
他们多久见你一次？
My mom sees me once a month, my dad, every three months.
我妈妈一个月见我一次，我爸爸，每三个月见一次。
Once a month and every three months. How close are you to them? Do you take them out for dinner? Do you always meet them at family holidays? Do you sit around the fireplace with them at night and roast marshmallows?
一个月一次和每三个月一次。你们关系有多亲密？你会带他们出去吃晚饭吗？你们总是会在家庭假期见面吗？你们会在晚上坐在壁炉旁烤棉花糖吗？
Those things are worth money?
这些东西值钱吗？
Absolutely. Loss of love and affection. In your case, there doesn't appear to be that strong an emotional relationship.
绝对值钱。失去爱和感情。在你的情况下，似乎没有那种强烈的情感关系。
Why not?  I'm very close to my parents.
为什么没有？我和我父母很亲密。
You see your dad once every three months. Does he send you a picture in between so you remember what he looks like?
你每三个月才见你爸爸一次。在这之间他会给你发照片让你记得他长什么样吗？
Oh, my god, this guy is totally fighting with Adam.
噢，天哪，这家伙完全在和亚当吵架。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I love that. I love it. Yeah. That's it. I mean, there's one more funny moment, if you wanted to play the--
我喜欢那个。我喜欢它。是的。就是那样。我是说，还有一个有趣的时刻，如果你想放……
Yeah, let's hear it.
是的，让我们听听。
I mean, it just comes right after that. It's like the next section, where he talks about-- he basically sort of hectors at him even more, because he says, there's one way that you could raise the value, is if you have a partner who loves you.
我是说，它就在那之后，就像下一部分，他谈到……他基本上对他进行了更多的严厉指责，因为他说，如果你有一个爱你的人，有一种方法可以提高价值。
Girlfriends don't count.
女朋友不算。
They don't count?
不算？
Absolutely not.
绝对不算。
I see my girlfriend every day and we're madly in love.
我每天都见我女朋友，我们疯狂地爱着对方。
If you love her that much, marry her. Show her the respect. Quit shacking up and marry her, and then she'll count.
如果你那么爱她，就娶她。给她那个尊重。别同居了，娶她，然后她就算了。
Yeah. That guy was amazing.
是的。那家伙太棒了。
Alex Blumberg. So as we've approached the 500th episode, I've been asked a lot about what stories and moments over the years are my favorites. And I'm asked that a lot in general, but that has totally stepped up lately. And some of my favorites really are the same shows, I think, that listeners pick when they pick their favorites.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。随着我们临近第 500 期节目，我经常被问到这些年来哪些故事和时刻是我最喜欢的。我通常会被问到这个问题，但最近频率完全增加了。而且我最喜欢的一些节目，我认为确实和听众挑选最爱时的节目是一样的。
There's the camp show. The aircraft carrier. "Harper High School." "Switched at Birth." Sarah Koenig's episode about the two Dr. Gilmers, recently. Starlee Kine's break-up story. "The Giant Pool of Money." The Harold Washington show-- forgive me for half minute, those of you who don't know our show so well, that I'm naming stuff without playing clips. There's no time to play all this stuff.
有夏令营节目。航空母舰。《哈珀高中》。“交换出生”。莎拉·凯尼格最近关于两个吉尔默医生的节目。斯塔莉·凯恩的分手故事。《巨额财富》。哈罗德·华盛顿的节目——原谅我打扰半分钟，那些不太了解我们节目的听众，我列举了一些而没有放片段。没有时间放所有这些东西了。
But I think honestly-- and I'm not totally proud of this-- a lot of my favorite moments are just things that I like for completely selfish reasons. Like I got a chance to say something that meant a lot to me for whatever reason. Or really, when the experience of making a story, just the experience of making it, meant a lot to me, like working on the episode last year after David Rakoff died.
但我坦率地认为——我并不以此为荣——我许多最喜欢的时刻仅仅是因为完全自私的原因而喜欢的。比如我有一个机会说出一些对我来说很有意义的话，无论出于什么原因。或者，当制作一个故事的经历，仅仅是制作它的经历对我来说意义重大时，比如去年戴维·拉科夫去世后制作的那一期。
Or back in the year 2000, I visited David Sedaris in Paris for a show. Or making a batch of Coca-Cola from what we believe is one of the original recipes. Or years ago, going to Medieval Times with a medieval scholar, who's now passed away. Or going to Georgia over and over and over and getting to know people and trying to get them to speak on the record about this small-town judge for the story I was doing.
或者早在 2000 年，我为了节目访问了巴黎的戴维·塞达里斯。或者根据我们认为是最初配方之一制作了一批可口可乐。或者几年前，和一位已经去世的中世纪学者去中世纪餐厅。或者一次又一次地去佐治亚州，去认识那里的人，并试图让他们在记录中谈论那个小镇法官，为了我正在做的那个故事。
Or my parents used to be on the show a lot, a lot, in the early years of the show. And I'll play you a clip. This is my mom, from our very first episode. Just listen to how skeptical she sounds at first in this clip.
或者我的父母在节目的早期经常出现在节目里。我会放一段片段给你听。这是我妈妈，来自我们的第一期节目。听听她在这个片段里起初听起来有多怀疑。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi, Mom?
嗨，妈妈？
Yeah.
是的。
Can I record a quick conversation with you about something?
我能录一段关于某事的简短对话吗？
What about?
关于什么？
Well, you know the new show goes on the air this week.
嗯，你知道新节目本周就要播出了。
Yeah.
是的。
Are you and dad still worried about me making a living in public radio? I mean, I know just for years, you were urging me just to get out and get basically any job in TV that I possibly could. But now that I've got my own show, are you guys still worried? Or do you feel like things are going OK?
你和爸爸还在担心我靠公共广播维生吗？我是说，我甚至多年来都知道，你们一直催促我离开并去电视行业找任何我能找的工作。但现在我有自己的节目了，你们还在担心吗？还是你们觉得一切都还好？
Now that Hugh Grant is such a big star, and everybody who sees you or sees your picture thinks how much you look like Hugh Grant, that sort of fires up that TV thing again in me. [LAUGHS]
既然休·格兰特现在是大明星了，所有看到你或看到你照片的人都会想你看起来多像休·格兰特，那在某种程度上又点燃了我心里的那个电视念头。[笑]
I'm just going to stop that clip. Can I just say? I look nothing like Hugh Grant. Only my mother could think I look like Hugh Grant.
我要停掉那个片段了。我可以只说一句吗？我看起来一点也不像休·格兰特。只有我妈妈才会觉得我看起来像休·格兰特。
Anyway, one of the big surprises, actually, of doing the radio show is that it brought me a lot closer with my parents. Things were pretty chilly between us before then because they disapproved of what I was doing with my life. I have joked in the past that my parents are the only Jews in America who do not like Public Radio. But having them be part of this thing that meant so much to me, being on the radio show, really made us closer in a way that I never anticipated could have happened.
总之，做这个电台节目真正的一个大惊喜是，它让我和父母走得更近了。在此之前，我们之间的关系相当冷淡，因为他们不赞成我用我的生活做的事。我过去开玩笑说我父母是美国仅有的不喜欢公共广播的犹太人。但让他们参与到对我意义重大的这件事中来，上电台节目，确实让我们以一种我从未预料到会发生的方式走得更近了。
And they came around on the Public Radio stuff. Here's my dad from show number 94-- this is February 1998-- coming on the air with some constructive criticism about the way that I read the show's credits.
而且他们确实改变了对公共广播的态度。这是我爸爸在第 94 期节目里——那是 1998 年 2 月——在节目里对我朗读节目学分的方式提出了一些建设性的批评。
Sometimes you just, you know, roll right through them without a lot of emotion, or maybe without sounding like a lot of caring. And well, you're just not giving it enough importance. You're anxious to beat the clock or something like that, or to get to a cup of coffee, or I don't know what.
有时你只是，你知道，毫无感情地就把它读过去了，或者可能没听起来有很多关心。而且嗯，你没有给它足够的重视。你急于赶时间或者是类似的事情，或者去喝杯咖啡，我不知道是什么。
Yeah. So give me some pointers. Give me some how-to.
是的。给我一些指点吧。教教我怎么做。
Well, I think you just ought to take your time and not rush through it so quickly.
嗯，我认为你只是应该从容一点，不要这么快就读完。
OK, enough of that. Hi, Dad.
好的，够了。嗨，爸爸。
OK, so I'd like to end the show today with this last story. This is one of Julie's picks. Here she is.
好的，我想用最后一个故事结束今天的节目。这是朱莉挑选的片段之一。她在这儿。
And the only reason I bring up this one is because I know a lot of people have told me, oh, that they've listened to the show and cried, or they hear a lot of different stories and it makes them cry.  Or I don't like listening to the show sometimes, because it totally makes me cry.
带出这一个的唯一原因是因为我知道很多人告诉我，噢，他们听了节目然后哭了，或者他们听到很多不同的故事，这让他们哭了。或者我不喜欢听节目，有时是因为它完全让我哭了。
I'm a little more hard-hearted. I don't cry as easily. I'm always like a little dumbfounded when people tell me about the things that made them cry. Sure, it's sad. I'm not gonna cry. Also, there's just the working here. Once you've heard something a couple of times and stuff, it doesn't make you cry anymore, you know?
我有点硬心肠。我没那么容易哭。当人们告诉我那些让他们哭的事情时，我总是有点目瞪口呆。当然，那很悲伤。我才不会哭。另外，这里的工作就是这样。一旦你听过几次什么东西，它就不会再让你哭了，你知道吗？
There is one story, and I have heard this story so many times. And then I had to listen to just to make sure that it held up before I came and talked to you. I cried. Seriously, like throat catching, cried walking down Seventh Avenue yesterday morning, coming into work. Of where I was like, oh my god, somebody's going to see that I'm crying.
有一个故事，我已经听过这个故事很多次了。然后我不得不听一次以确保它在我进来和你谈话之前还能站得住脚。我哭了。认真的，就像喉咙发紧，昨天早上走在第七大道上走着去上班时哭了。那种我当时心想，噢天哪，有人要看到我在哭了。
To my own show.
为了我自己的节目。
[BOTH LAUGH]
[两人大笑]
A story that I totally know how this goes.
一个我完全知道是怎么回事的故事。
What story is it?
是什么故事？
I can't believe you don't obviously know.
我不敢相信你竟然不知道。
What is it?
是什么？
"Mama, I'm Sorry."
《妈妈，对不起》。
Awww.
噢。
Oh, it gets me every time.
噢，它每次都触动我。
OK, all right. So this is from our show "20 Acts in 60 Minutes."
好的，好的。所以这是来自我们《60分钟里的20幕》节目。
Yep.
是的。
Act 20. "The Greatest Moment I Ever Saw On a Stage." I'll say, first of all, that this moment that I saw caught me completely off-guard. I was at a play where I was not expecting anything special. It was put on by an organization that works with teenagers. Music Theater Workshop is what it's called. And among other things, they get kids who are locked up in Chicago's juvenile detention center, the Audy Home, to write and perform musicals about their lives.
第 20 幕。“我在舞台上见过的最伟大的时刻”。我首先会说，我看到的这个时刻完全让我措手不及。当时我在看一场我没期待会有什么特别内容的戏。它是由一个与青少年合作的组织演出的。它叫音乐剧研讨会。除此之外，他们让被关在芝加哥青少年管教所——奥迪之家——的孩子们编写并表演关于他们生活的音乐剧。
This one was performed by teenage girls. OK, so we're in the detention center. Folding chairs have been set up. The girl's parents-- it's mostly mothers and grandmothers, very few men-- are sitting directly in front of the stage.
这一部是由十几岁的女孩表演的。好吧，我们在管教所里。折叠椅已经摆好了。女孩们的父母——主要是母亲和祖母，很少有男人——直接坐在舞台前面。
And imagine for a minute what it's like to be one of those parents, OK? Your kid's locked up, possibly on very serious charges, some of these girls were. You're worried about what's going to happen to them next. You're probably still mad that they didn't listen to you in the first place and got into all this trouble, and ended up behind bars.
试着想象一下作为那些父母中的一个是什么感觉，好吗？你的孩子被关起来了，可能面临非常严重的指控，这些女孩中有些是这样的。你担心他们接下来会发生什么。你可能还在生他们的气，因为他们起初没听你的话，陷入了所有这些麻烦，并最终被关进监狱。
What can theater possibly do for you in this situation? You know? It seems like such an old-fashioned idea that it can do anything.
在这种情况下，戏剧到底能为你做什么？你知道吗？它看起来就像是一个能做任何事情的老派想法。
So there's this one scene in the play.
所以戏里有一幕。
Where'd you get these clothes from?
你从哪里弄来的这些衣服？
And it's a story of this girl named Candace. And Candace basically wanted better clothes so the other kids at school wouldn't laugh at her. And she steals some clothes from Nike Town and she gets in trouble. She gets caught.
这是一个叫坎迪斯女孩的故事。坎迪斯基本上想要更好的衣服，这样学校里的其他孩子就不会嘲笑她。她从耐克城偷了一些衣服，然后惹上了麻烦。她被抓住了。
And then she joins a gang to earn some money and be more popular. Her mom finds some drugs in the house, and a gun, and feels completely betrayed because that was not how she raised her daughter. And one thing leads to another, and Candace gets locked up.
然后她加入了一个帮派来赚取一些钱并变得更受欢迎。她妈妈在房子里发现了一些毒品和一把枪，感到完全被背叛了，因为那不是她抚养女儿的方式。一件事情导致另一件事情，坎迪斯被关起来了。
Then the girl narrating the story says, and this is how Candace feels about her mom now. And then all the girls in the play come out on the stage and stand in a line, facing their mothers and grandmothers who are right there in front of them.
然后讲故事的女孩说，这就是坎迪斯现在对自己妈妈的感受。然后剧里的所有女孩都走上舞台，站成一排，面对着就在她们前面的母亲和祖母。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING)  Mama, I'm sorry for what I have done. I was arrested and ended up here in the Audy Home. Oh, I'm sorry for putting you through all of this. I know you are mad about the good times that we miss. I'm ready to come back home. I'm willing to make a change.
（唱歌）妈妈，对不起我所做的一切。我被捕了，最终被关进了奥迪之家。噢，对不起让你经历了这一切。我知道你对我们错过的美好时光很生气。我准备好回家了。我愿意做出改变。
One of the verses goes, Mama, I'm sorry for making you come to court, for almost losing your job to give me moral support. Mama, I'm sorry for putting you through all the stress, for making you worry yourself and depressed. I'm ready to come back home. I'm willing to make a change.
其中一节歌词是，妈妈，对不起让你来到法庭，为了给我精神支持差点失去你的工作。妈妈，对不起让你承受这一切压力，让你担心自己并陷入抑郁。我准备好回家了。我愿意做出改变。
And by this time, the girls are all crying. The parents are all crying. And each girl has a cut-out-- you know, like a little heart, like on Valentine's Day? Like that, made from red construction paper. Like the size of your palm. And written on each one is the words "I'm sorry."
到这个时候，女孩们都在哭。父母们都在哭。每个女孩手里都拿着一个剪纸——你知道，就像情人节那样的红心？那样，用红色建筑纸做的。就像你的手掌那么大。每个上面都写着“对不起”。
And each girl goes out to the audience, to where her mom is sitting or her grandma is sitting and hands her the heart. And the parents are crying, and the kids are crying, and everybody is hugging. It was really something.
每个女孩都走到观众席，走到她妈妈或祖母坐的地方，把心递给她。父母在哭，孩子在哭，每个人都在拥抱。这真的太感人了。
(SINGING)  I'll do anything for you, Mama. Please forget about yesterday. Mama, I'm sorry.
（唱歌）妈妈，我会为你做任何事。请忘记昨天的一切。妈妈，对不起。
Here they were, not just saying this to their mothers, but saying it publicly, in front of the world, in front of their friends. Saying this thing that could be so hard to say in any case, you know? Singing it out, and hoping it can heal something that is going to be hard to heal, no matter what you do.
她们就在这里，不仅是对她们的母亲说，而且是公开地说，在世界面前，在朋友面前。说出这句话在任何情况下都可能很难，你知道吗？唱出来，并希望它能治愈一些东西，无论你做什么，这些东西都将很难治愈。
(SINGING)  Mama, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
（唱歌）妈妈，对不起。对不起。对不起。
(TEARFULLY BUT LAUGHING)  Isn't it the worst?
（含泪但笑着）这不是最糟糕的吗？
You're crying?
你在哭吗？
I find it so sad.
我觉得它太悲伤了。
(SINGING)  I'm sorry. Sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Mama, I'm sorry.
（唱歌）对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。对不起。妈妈，对不起。
[MUSIC - MATT POSS BAND, "AMERICAN LIFE"]
[音乐 - 马特·波斯乐队，《美国生活》]
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder.
好了，我们今天的节目由莎拉·凯尼格和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、三木·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。
Thanks today to all the other producers who have worked on the show over the years, who did such a beautiful job making the stories that you heard today-- Peter Clowney, Alix Spiegel, Doris Wilbur, Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Wendy Dorr, Starlee Kine, Jonathan Goldstein, Diane Cook, John Jeter, and Jane Feltes AKA Jane MariE.
感谢今天所有多年来在节目中工作过的其他制作人，他们出色地完成了今天你们听到的故事的制作——彼得·克劳尼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、多丽丝·威尔伯、苏珊·伯顿、布鲁·切维尼、温迪·多尔、斯塔莉·凯恩、乔纳森·戈德斯坦、黛安·库克、约翰·杰特和简·费尔特斯，也就是简·玛丽。
Thanks bigger than I think thanks can actually say to Torey Malatia, who I started the radio show with at WBEZ. Production help today from Thea Benin. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Robb Geddes.
我能想到的最大的感谢要送给托雷·马拉蒂亚，我和他在 WBEZ 一起开始了这档电台节目。今天的制作帮助来自西娅·贝宁。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米莉·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯。
Our website, where we have added all kinds of extra stuff this week for the 500th episode-- thanks to Rich Orris for helping with that. And where you can listen to all 500 episodes for absolutely free on your computer or using our app on your cellphone or iPad. We also have lists that we hope are helpful of listeners' favorite shows at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站，本周我们为第 500 期节目增加了各种额外的内容——感谢里奇·奥里斯对此的帮助。在那里你可以在电脑上或在手机或 iPad 上使用我们的应用程序完全免费收听全部 500 期节目。我们在网站 thisamericanlife.org 上还有我们希望对听众有所帮助的听众最爱节目清单。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. I hope my father heard me read these credits and felt I did OK. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this message today.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我希望我父亲听到了我读这些演职员表，并觉得我做得还可以。我们节目由 WBEZ 管理层监督，由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他今天有这个信息。
Hello, I'm Torey Malatia. I am a real person. Happy 500th episode. Now get back to work.
你好，我是托雷·马拉蒂亚。我是一个真人。第 500 期节目快乐。现在回去工作。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - MATT POSS BAND, "AMERICAN LIFE"]
[音乐 - 马特·波斯乐队，《美国生活》]
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。